today on the matt walsh show another
company comes out in support of the
marxist blm organization while
discriminating against conservatives
it's time for conservatives such as
myself
to get over our aversion to boycott so
we'll talk about that today also five
headlines including the dnc convention
speech
by an accused rapist who was
photographed receiving a massage
from one of epstein's sex slaves and in
our daily cancellation i'll cancel msnbc
anchor chris hayes
and in the process of that cancellation
just for good measure i'm also going to
cancel college so it's all going to work
together
and that will make sense when we get to
it all of that on the way but first
you already know about rock auto great
sponsors of this show and a great
company especially if you're tired of
going to the auto parts store only to
not find what you're looking for
inevitably
and then you wasted all that time time
is precious and rockauto.com is so much
easier than walking into a store
someone demanding quick answers to
things like is your odyssey an lx or an
ex
and then they usually get to have to go
online and order the part anyway because
there are so many
types of cards it's impossible to keep
them all stocked you have to
access uh rockauto.com at your desk and
in your pocket you've got the access
right there
you don't need to go to the store to um
to get what you need rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts rockauto.com
look it's a family business serving auto
parts customers online for 20 years
you can go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all the prices at rockauto.com
are reliably low
and they're the same for professionals
for do-it-yourselfers doesn't matter who
so you're getting the best possible
prices you're getting the best uh
you know possible selection it doesn't
really make sense to spend more money
more time more effort for a smaller
selection
and less convenience that just that that
calculation makes no sense and that's
why
i go to rockauto.com and you should too
go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car truck and write walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that
we sent you all right let's um
so let's let's get into this there's
sort of the eternal question
why do conservatives tend to always lose
culture war battles while leftists tend
to win
now there's more than one answer to that
question it's a multi-faceted sort of
issue but but one answer one big answer
is certainly this the left
is not afraid to apply pressure the
right
oftentimes is and i'll explain
more of what i mean by that but here's
why i'm bringing this up
here's the the story the setup wibw a
local news station in topeka kansas
reports that a recent diversity training
seminar at the goodyear topeka plant
included a slide outlining the company's
zero tolerance policy and the image was
posted to social media apparently by an
employee
who saw this and uh and didn't like it
for good reason
he says the material originates from
goodyear corporate headquarters in
ohio so listed as you can see it here
listed as acceptable messages
are black lives matter and lgbt pride
the unacceptable column consists of blue
lives matter
all lives matter magga and political
slogans
now goodyear has not specifically
addressed the discriminatory slide
but it did issue a statement when it was
contacted by the the local media here's
the statement says goodyear is committed
to fostering an inclusive and respectful
respectful workplace where all of our
associates can do their best
in a spirit of teamwork and part of this
commitment we
do allow our associates to express their
support on racial injustice and other
equity issues
but as they refrain from workplace
expressions verbal or otherwise in
support of political campaigning
or for any candidate or political party
as well as other similar forms of
advocacy that fall outside the scope
of equity issues now this is outrageous
on a number of levels first of all
all lives matter is about as
non-political as a slogan gets
political messages are tribalistic
exclusionary by nature
somebody who affirms that all lives
matter is expressly rejecting tribalism
and defending the dignity of human life
universally so the statement is not only
non-political but it is in fact
anti-political and it's not as though
all lives matter is an
unnecessary thing to say that of course
is the claim from el from blm supporters
they say
well there's no reason to proclaim all
lives matter and so if you proclaim it
then it can only be as some sort of
counter protest against blm well
even if it is a counter protest against
blm so what there's plenty there to
protest but
it's not merely that we happen to live
in a culture
where the dignity and value of human
life is not
universally affirmed we do kill a
million babies a year in the womb
after all and beyond that many people
are murdered in our communities every
day and if their deaths are not
politically useful to the cultural
powers that be
their deaths are treated as
inconsequential which is to say their
lives are treated as
inconsequential as not mattering and one
of the main culprits in dismissing and
ignoring these deaths and these lives
is black lives matter now if blue lives
matter is political it's only because
one side of the political isle has
decided to
uh stake out this this position of
defining itself by its raw hatred of law
enforcement
that doesn't make the message inherently
divisive
all decent and sane people a dwindling
demographic to be sure
can agree that the lives of police
officers matter in fact
goodyear itself one seemed to feel this
way in the past the company has offered
discounts to law enforcement officers
other first responders
even now if you go to their website they
brag that they're a recognized leader
quote unquote in providing tires for
police cars
hopefully police unions will be calling
for those contracts to be pulled you
know i certainly wouldn't want to buy
tires from a company
that doesn't think my life matters that
seems like a disaster waiting to happen
imagine going to a doctor's office that
bans you from wearing a shirt that says
patience lives matter what about black
lives matter well
if marxism counts as a political
ideology and
it does last i checked then blm is an
intensely political organization it is
co-founded by a woman who describes
herself and her comrades as
trained marxists who are quote
superversed on quote
ideological theories the what we believe
section of the blm website is full of
these ideological theories such as the
theory that
the western prescribed nuclear family
structure should be disrupted
and that cisgender privilege should be
quote dismantled
and blm has indeed done quite a bit of
dismantling over the years
i don't know if they've dismantled
cisgender privilege whatever that is but
they have left entire city blocks in
ruins you got to start somewhere i guess
now goodyear is certainly not alone many
of the most powerful corporations in
america
have endorsed and offered financial
support to black lives matter
of course it's only by virtue of its
name that this a validly marxist
organization which has been
involved in rioting and looting in
cities across the country for years
has managed to gain such widespread
mainstream acceptance
if blm had a more accurate name like
marxist
united or something similar i doubt very
much that pepsi and goodyear would be
lining up behind it
that's how silly our political discourse
has become
simply change the name of blm keep
everything else the same everything
change the name and i'm betting there'd
be 85
agreement in america that it's a hate
group at a minimum if not a domestic
terror group which
is my vote and there would be none but
the most avowedly left wing of companies
coming out in its defense
so be all that as it may corporations
that support
marxist organizations while censoring
messages of support for groups like
police officers
should face a severe penalty from their
customer base
conservatives myself included tend to
shy away from boycotts
i can tell you that in the past i have
scoffed at them
and i still scoff at boycotts that are
frivolous or launched for stupid reasons
and i certainly won't participate in any
boycott meant to punish a company for
the
privately held views of one of its
employees even it's
you know even if it's its ceo or founder
the ceo of goodyear can have whatever
opinion he wants
i don't care if he personally favors the
legal legalization of cannibalism
which would be only slightly more
offensive than the policies advocated by
blm
um private companies and private
opinions rather are one thing but when
an entire company
takes a side on an issue and makes its
position explicit
then we have every reason to take notice
and if they make it clear
that they have no respect for people
like us that is people who believe all
lives matter and police lives matter
and if they side with violent radical
marxists
well then we would have to be
certifiable masochists to continue
supporting them
there's no reason to lots of companies
sell tires
not all of them do so while spouting
marxist talking points so
me you know i'll take the tires without
the marxism thanks
so now is a good time to get over our
aversion
to applying this kind of pressure um
it's an aversion i understand because as
i said i
share it uh you know there is there is
something in me constitutionally
that recoils at boycotts i kind of i
kind of recoil it marching
in the street with signs also though
i've done it a number of times in fact
but
there is i believe still something in
the conservative mindset that
militates against this sort of activism
and i don't think it's a need to be
polite because i don't have any need to
be polite at all
i think it might be our fundamental
practicality you know we aren't as into
holding signs because it doesn't feel
practical or useful we don't like
boycotting because frankly
if a company has something i want and
they have the best price and they have
uh and and you know they're nearby then
i just want to go buy it and when i'm in
the car and maybe i'm with my family
and the kids are crying and and i need
whatever product i don't feel like
thinking about these kinds of issues or
trying to be socially conscious or
political in my
buying decisions i've got more pressing
concerns in that moment
i'm in real life mode and so i think
that's where the aversion comes from
if i'm if i'm psychoanalyzing myself and
other conservatives
it's from practicality but it's an
aversion we need to overcome because
um you know besides boycotting is a
rather practical thing to do
all we are doing is listening to a
company tell us its position and taking
it seriously believing what it says and
responding accordingly
goodyear apparently doesn't want my
business who am i to force it upon them
many companies don't want my business or
your business
or the business of so many millions of
us and we should stop giving it to them
out of basic self-respect and even
respect for them and their wishes
and that's why goodyear won't see
another dime from me which is not an
idol threat by the way this isn't one of
those boycotts
where you're boycotting a company you've
never patronized anyway
like when leftists boycott a hardware
store or a gun shop
i've patronized goodyear many times but
no more
and i think this should be the approach
across the board from here on out
no more propping up companies that hate
us
those days have to be over and you know
when we talk about the practicality
thing because i was thinking about it
this morning
um trying to figure out like what what
is it about why have i
in the past been so anti-boycott and i
do think it's it's it's the practical
thing and you see this difference
between conservatives and and like i
said i know i'm psychoanalyzing her but
you see this difference between
conservatives and and leftists
conservatives tend to be very practical
minded very common sense
i mean you think about the typical sort
of
suburban middle-aged republican dad
you know that's that's like one of your
quintessential conservative types right
and that's going to be someone who um
and you know that's
sort of me i don't know if i'm
middle-aged yet but um
that's someone who who you know it's it
just just isn't that interested
in in in in activism it isn't going to
show up and hold a sign that's the kind
of person you know your dad is driving
down the road and just
like you need something you pull in
and if you try if you're a kid and you
try to shut no no we can't shop there
dad it's
because of their position oh shut up we
got to go in here and buy this
um and that's kind of how we think now
leftists on the other hand
are not as plagued by practicality and
common sense they don't have to worry
about that now
that handicaps them in their day-to-day
life but it makes them
much more effective activists
and so i think this has to be the
balance that we have to strike not that
we give up common sense
but that we start being willing to do
things that are a little bit impractical
because that's what's going to be
necessary in order to engage in this
culture fight all right let's go to our
five headlines
another night of the dnc last night god
help us
i didn't watch it again because i don't
hate myself well i do hate myself but
not enough to expose myself to such
tortures intentionally
the highlight of the night though had to
be accused rapist bill clinton giving
his speech which was so
laid in with irony that you know it may
cause an overdose
so here's bill for example giving a
lecture on how to behave in the oval
office
donald trump says we're leading the
world well we are the only major
industrial economy
to have its unemployment rate tripled at
a time like this
the oval office should be a command
center instead it's a storm center
there's only chaos just one thing never
changes
his determination to deny responsibility
and shift the blame
the buck never stops there
now you have to decide whether to renew
his contract or hire someone else
if you want a president who defines the
job of spending hours a day watching tv
and zapping people on social media he's
your man
they really might as well have michael
moore come give a lecture on nutrition
and fitness
i mean i mean they might as well have
elizabeth warren speak at the native
american caucus meeting
oh wait no they they actually did that
too um
yeah they're yes they're they are trying
to give us an irony overdose i think
that's that's the dastardly plot here
now as for slick willie uh we should
remember that clinton didn't just take
advantage of a young
intern while he was president and lie
about it uh and perjure himself he
and he wasn't just accused of sexual
harassment multiple times by multiple
women he was also accused of rape
violent forcible rape credibly accused
a lot of even the critical coverage of
bill's dnc speech
makes no mention of the rape accusation
for example
a piece in the daily beast eloquently
titled why the f is creepy bill clinton
speaking at the democratic convention
doesn't so they cut right to the chase
with the title i like that but it
doesn't make any reference to the rape
charge
it excoriates the dnc for having bill
clinton because he's a dinosaur he
represents the past he's antiquated and
so on
um and uh and yes he was inappropriate
with some women but
but even the critics of clinton can't on
the left anyway can't bring themselves
to admit
that he was credibly accused of pushing
a woman down on a hotel bed
and forcibly violating her the other
thing uh not mentioned
is bill's many many trips to and fro
with
global pedophile and sex trafficker
jeffrey epstein
speaking of which new photos emerged
yesterday you can take a look at that
uh there's creepy bill as we're calling
him now keeping getting a massage
from one of epstein's sex trafficking
victims
and unless you are naive to the point of
being essentially catatonic
you should know that there is nothing
innocent about going on a trip with your
pedophile buddy
and getting a massage from one of his
sex slaves in fact we have heard
from epstein's victims that these
massages were part of the grooming
ritual
so this is certainly nothing innocent
here and this is big news what you're
seeing right here
a former president being massaged by a
sex-trafficked
girl in the company of an international
pedophile
but you wouldn't know it from the media
coverage which is uh
which has been almost non-existent
number two
it's like groundhog day at this point
reporting this every day but uh i'm not
gonna ignore it blm
rioters in portland again last night
um as we go into our what is it third
month of this and they attacked a police
station set it on fire
here's the footage of that
here hold this one yep
we've really reached a point where
left-wing demonstrators setting a police
station on fire is
like par for the course well they set
another police station on fire
well what are you gonna do there was a
time
when this would have been treated as a
very big deal
and it is a big deal and should still be
treated
as such and this is why
speaking of conservatives being
ineffective uh
the argument that you hear from a lot of
conservatives is that
well we shouldn't really do anything and
trump shouldn't do anything
uh because we you know th this these are
leftist cities
and just let them destroy themselves and
you know that's how we stick it to the
left is by letting them destroy
themselves
uh i think there are a lot of problems
with that mentality
starting with the fact that not
everybody in
one of these cities is there are just
normal decent people living in these
cities that are being victimized here
they're not all a bunch of crate if it
was a city entirely comprised of violent
lunatic left-wing activists
then i would say yeah just let them you
know it's it's lord of the flies and
just
let them do what they're going to do but
uh or maybe i would say that actually
i probably even then wouldn't but it's
certainly not in this case because there
are actual
victims in these cases and then the
second point
is um even aside from that
we are letting the criminals do what
they want i don't understand how that's
supposed to be some sort of punishment
i don't know how that's supposed to be
us winning by
letting them letting them commit crimes
letting them
with impunity do whatever they want no
that is letting the criminals win we are
we are letting them win
by letting them do what they want and
i don't think we should it only
emboldens them and it only guarantees
more of this in the future i think it's
a terrible strategy
it's not really a strategy at all it's a
non-strategy it's just it's just doing
nothing
number three reading from the daily wire
says massachusetts officials are
reportedly calling the police and the
state's department of children and
families
on parents whose children fail to show
up for their school district's
zoom school those are the the classes
that are live streamed
the boston globe reports that
massachusetts school officials have
reported dozens of families to state
social workers for possible neglect
because of issues related to their
children's participation in remote
learning classes during the pandemic
shutdown in the spring
in most cases the outlet notes the
referrals were made solely because the
students failed to log into class
repeatedly
most of the parents reported were
mothers and several did not have any
previous involvement with social
services so now they have that on their
record
um and of course you can you could
totally see why
a parent wouldn't bother having their
kid log into the zoom class
because you know if if we're doing this
i can just teach them myself right
there's no reason for
i'm not going to have my kid sit in a
computer sit in front of a computer all
day to learn this is not the right way
i'll just do it myself
i think a lot of parents were saying
that and now they get visits from social
services
and this of course goes back to what we
discussed last week that the school
system
thinks it owns your child that your
children belong to it
so even when they shut down
and don't let your child come to school
they still want to keep tabs
they still are owed in their minds your
child's attention and allegiance and
obedience
and they will literally try to throw you
in jail if you don't comply
i really think a day will come when
people look back on this kind of thing
look back on the modern public school
system
in general and just shake their heads in
horror and disbelief
thinking like how did parents ever
subject their children to that
intentionally
that's what they'll ask and it'll be a
good question and the thing is
i don't have a good answer even now uh
though i'm living through it
number four fox news reports important
story here
um very important it says a bride
recently posted online about how her
mother gave a vicious speech at her
wedding last year which led the
groomsmen
to ask her mother to leave the reception
in the post on reddit's
am i the a-hole forum uh the pro the
bride a user
of the forum explained that she didn't
really feel comfortable allowing her mom
to speak at a wedding because of their
strained relationship
she says quote i ultimately let her
hoping she would deliver the same fluff
about gaining a son that she did at my
sister's wedding
according to the red post the mom
insulted the bride's appearance her
quote crappy apartment and her gross
medical issues this is during the the
speech at the reception
she said each time she paused to let a
joke land there was silence
my husband and wedding party stared at
me frozen waiting for my cue on how to
react
they stayed seated in until her bit
about how i am damaged goods referring
to a time when i was 19. i had a bad
date and the guy harassed me for over a
year it seriously impacted my mental
health and i dropped out of college it's
painful to think or talk about
then it goes on to say that the mom was
asked to leave the wedding and she's
very offended by that now there's a
strained relationship with the daughter
even more strained as you can imagine
all right just just just two quick
points here
um the reason i bring this up this story
and first of all the first one is i have
been to
plenty of weddings and i have never
witnessed a moment like this
and so i'm pretty jealous i've never
seen anything this entertaining
also this is an opportunity for me
really to go over what i believe the
rules should be
for wedding receptions um because the
way we go about wedding receptions is
all wrong
wedding receptions are exhausting and
excruciating
for for everybody involved uh they're
really not a lot of fun
and it doesn't have to be this way now
this one sounds like it was pretty
entertaining but usually they aren't
uh but but but they would be if
everybody followed my rules so let me
tell you what the rules are and of
course when i am
when i when i take over and my reign
begins as theocratic dictator these
rules will be
uh will be codified into law and
punishable by death
or a 50 fine or both uh number one
if you aren't gonna have booze at your
wedding you should be
legally barred from getting married dry
wedding receptions
are a violation of the eighth eighth
amendments
ban on cruel and unusual punishment i
almost said they're a violation of the
ten commandments which they which i
would say they even are that too somehow
especially a dry wedding where i don't
know if you've ever been to one of these
a dry wedding no alcohol but they still
have music and dancing
now if you're gonna go puritan then go
full puritan have no alcohol no dancing
we'll get in and out in 15 minutes and
if we're doing that then okay fine
i'll allow that but you want to have a
four and a half hour reception
with music and dancing but no alcohol
like
you think you're going to get us onto
the floor for the cha cha slide and we
have had no beer ahead of time
not going to happen number two wedding
reception food
is usually a letdown there are some
exceptions to this i went to my friend's
wedding last year
uh he's indian so he had indian food
like curry and stuff like that it was
very very good
so that you know there are some
exceptions but usually the food is bad
so uh just what i would say no food
people pack a lunch a ham sandwich
really it's about the booze anyway third
thing finally more to the point of this
story all speeches should be banned at
wedding receptions
giving an effective speech is actually a
highly difficult skill to master and
99.9
of people in the world do not have the
skill that's why most speeches you hear
at weddings at fundraising banquets and
other types of events
are horrendous because they're be they
aren't being delivered by trained
professionals they're being delivered by
amateurs who have no idea what they're
doing
so uh that's what i would say either
have no speeches at all
how egotistical is it anyway to carve
out time
in your wedding reception for people to
get up and say nice things about you
so you're planning it and you're saying
okay so at this point here in the
schedule we'll have 47 people
take turns uh saying nice things about
us into a microphone
yeah that's a good idea absolute
narcissism
uh so no speeches or you can hire a
trained professional to give
one speech just one and on that note i
am available
a rate of 95 a word not a bad
considering how much you spend at
weddings really that's
that's a pretty good bargain all right
number so those are those are the rules
uh
five finally we have
one more headline these aren't really
headlines but uh but just go with it
lena dunham of course one of the great
minds and great talents of our time has
given us another offering
um another thing to think about and i
just want to play that for you here it
is
[Music]
yeah i'm sorry i just i saw that
i felt like i had to deal with it
psychologically because i was exposed to
it
and so then i exposed you to it also
really misery loves company i had to do
it
and i just why
why maybe this isn't the lead here i
don't know but why is she wearing a
bathing suit
that says sex on it like
that's about the that when it comes to
being a provocateur that's about on the
level of when you're in middle school
and you type numbers into your
calculator and turn it upside down so it
says boobs you know
it's like on that level this is someone
who wants to be provocative
but has run out of tricks there are no
more tricks in her bag she reached into
her bag came up empty
and said oh i know i'll i'll i'll wear a
bathing suit that says sex on it
super edgy stuff so there's lena dunham
that's what she's up to if you're
wondering
and we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation but first um
you know we've been telling you about
our all-access membership tier most
exclusive membership here at the daily
wire all access members get to join all
access live which is our exclusive live
stream discussions hosted every night
by each of the hosts including myself
and this thursday august 20th i am
so excited to be doing this i cannot
tell you how absolutely ecstatic i am
um that we will be doing a very special
live stream uh
watch party covering the democratic
national conventions biggest speakers
hosted by none other than me okay we're
gonna watch this thing i
i am so thrilled to be doing it i i hope
that you join in
um i am not at all planning
to have wi-fi difficulties that night so
that i can't do it i i'm certainly would
not plan for something like that at all
i'm hoping that that doesn't happen and
that this thing
can go forward i cannot wait um
dailywire.com
walsh 20 off all access with coupon code
access against dailywire.comwalsh
for our daily cancellation today i'll be
canceling msnbc host chris hayes and
this i believe is chris's first
appearance on the daily cancellation but
not for lack of trying
and uh you know when i tell you what
precipitated this
uh the reason for the cancellation may
be other than what you think so there
have been
these boat parades popping up over the
last several weeks trump
boat parades these are i guess trump
supporters who own boats and who get
together and do a parade
to express their support for trump
i don't personally really understand the
point of that uh goes back to the whole
practicality thing but whatever hey you
know it's an excuse to take the boat out
anyway and if you can put some lines out
and do
do a little trolling while you're at it
uh maybe trolling in more
more ways than one then even better now
chris was going back and forth
with washington post reporter dave weigl
on twitter talking about this
boat parade phenomenon and one thing you
should understand is that
anytime trump supporters whether by land
air or sea
come out in public people like chris
hayes and dave weigl will leer at them
and want to analyze and study them
like they're a baboon troop or something
and
this time they were talking about it and
debating
and they both agreed that as hayes put
it white men without four-year degree
and disposable income enough to buy a
boat are genuinely the trump base
that's his analysis my issue here with
hayes and the reason for his
cancellation is not that he's being
condescending to trump supporters
that's not even worth remarking on
anymore i mean yes of course he is
that's just that comes with the
territory
it's that his method of condescension
just reveals how
silly and one-track-minded he is now he
obviously means this as an insult white
man without degrees but who could buy
boats or trump's base that's an insult
but what he's really saying is that
trump's base consists of people smart
creative and ambitious enough to forgo
the college path and yet still achieve
enough
achieve enough financial success to buy
a boat
so to people like chris having a degree
is a status symbol
right having even more pieces of paper
your master's your phd whatever
gives you even more status and that's
all it is to him that's all it is to
people like him
that's why they get so upset and
offended when people skip college
and don't end up in trailer parks
working the graveyard shift
stat stocking shelves at walmart like
they're supposed to
uh in chris's mind that's what it's
supposed to that's what's supposed to
happen and nothing against
people who live in trailer parks and
work the graveyard shift at walmart my
point is that chris hayes and other
elitist snobs
have a very specific idea of what your
life course is supposed to be
if you don't go to college the main
thing is
you're not supposed to be financially
successful and you're certainly not
supposed to make more money than they do
but when you defy those expectations
and you know you really misbehave and
you go off script
and you ad lib and um and you skip
college and after years of hard work you
end up even more successful than some of
the elitist snobs themselves
well they don't like that and so they'll
try to insult you
on the basis that you don't have the
mere piece of paper
and that's why the piece of paper itself
becomes the status symbol
not the success it's supposed to afford
you the success
you can get without the paper they know
that so they'll still try to go yeah
well you're making good money you own a
boat
you're living the dream but you don't
have this and they wave in your face the
framed degree that cost them 30 years of
debt and a damaged libert liver to
obtain
and that's why i'm canceling chris hayes
but really as you may have already
gathered i bring up chris hayes mostly
as an excuse to launch into
my rant about college in general i'll
take any opportunity presented to me
uh no matter how much i have to stretch
to to get from a to b so
leaving chris hayes aside for a moment
let me say again
and probably for the 10 billionth time
going to college should not be
the automatic and perfunctory path
it should not be the default college is
not necessary for obtaining success in
life
it isn't even necessary for obtaining
your own boat as we've covered
college is and ought to be seen as a
very specific course of action taken for
specific and expressible reasons
reasons like i want to be a doctor or i
want to get into engineering
okay those are great reasons to go to
college though even in those cases i
don't see any particular reason
why a kid just out of high school has to
jump right into it
why not take a few years off work a job
or two make some money get some life
experience i can't fathom
the downside of that oh i'll fall behind
if it fall behind who
who are you racing and why but most
people don't go to college with any
particular
job or career in mind um they just go
because
that's what you do they're told that's
what everyone does
and by that's what everyone does we mean
that this has been the standard
operating procedure for compared to the
history of human civilization about five
and a half seconds
but we've decided that the way stuff has
worked for five and a half seconds is
the only way
it can ever work again we're wrong and
even as we
shuffle our kids into these institutions
blackmailing them coercing them pushing
them
forcing them into college we complain
that it's expensive
now the institutions are overrun with
leftist brainwashers which they are
we say in one breath junior you must go
to college or you're going to fail at
life
and in the next we say oh god colleges
are terrible and expensive and they're
turning kids into brainwashed zombies
it doesn't make a lot of sense and
even leaving aside the ideological
issues how much sense does it make for a
kid
to go to college just so he can figure
out if he needs to go to college
we tell them even if they don't know
what they want to do with their lives
to go ahead and take out the six
six-figure loan as some sort of
ticket to a really expensive voyage of
self-discovery
spend the money to find out if you
really needed to spend the money
it's like charging someone for chemo
before you even get the biopsy results
back it doesn't it just
in any other context we would consider
it reckless
and ridiculous a much more reasonable
less expensive less risky less fraught
path is to graduate high school go into
the workforce have some life experience
figure yourself out
figure out what you want to do what your
skills are your passions your goals and
then
if it becomes apparent that a college
education is a necessary piece of your
puzzle
go and get the education this is a lot
better than trying to cram the piece
into place before you even know if it
belongs to your puzzle or not
so there's my college rant and anyway
chris hayes is canceled and college is
cancelled too we canceled both
two birds one stone that'll do it for
today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20. hey everybody it's
andrew clavin host of the andrew clavin
show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton